your latest film is about women
empowerment I know that's something that
you're very very strongly about what is
the name of the film and if you can tell
us a story about you know well thank you
this is a one of some something I'm
really really excited about my film is
called sue legacy kadaga and the tagline
is be fluid as water and suli Casey
kadaga means caught in the whirlpool Wow
and it's not an action film like you
said it's a woman empowerment film but
the cot in the whirlpool means got in
the whirlpool of life taking you down
swirling down towards destruction you
know how circumstances of life
especially for women in so many
situations across the world just spiral
them out of control you know oh they
can't they don't have control over so
many things and that always breaks my
heart you know because me being a woman
first of all I'm all for humanity and
human improvement and human potential
and getting rid of human suffering but
especially women because it has come to
that it has come to the point where we
really as women need to stand together
for each other every single woman needs
to support every other single women
across the planet you know their their
their education their safety their their
home situations you know what happens
within the homes for women they don't
have a voice many times and when they
get that voice out there is pandemonium
instead of support there is pandemonium
so I am all for women empowerment and
our this film is a it's got four
components it is about a young woman in
india I will not tell the story yet but
I will give the the components of it
because as I said I always the house of
pundit productions I
want to have an awareness built into it
apart from the entertaining story so
this one's also directed by sandeep
Milani in India but because i am a
tucson-based person now I was I also
wanted to start getting films made in
Tucson so this film for the first time
in a production about fifteen percent of
it is filmed in Tucson so we have a
Tucson director as well scott barker is
his name so we have an indian director
and the u.s. director so somehow this
new film the medical awareness cause
that came into my my consciousness which
I wanted to put across as grand mal
epilepsy you know such a common thing
that we see in the hospital all the time
in the emergency room we see it all the
time and we as doctors it is easy for us
to treat it you know we we can treat the
condition we can give them advice we can
give them follow up but I also see the
strong across the world there is a
stigma attached to grand mal epilepsy in
so many areas of the world you know if
it appears you you see a person having a
grand mall attack in public it makes
people afraid it makes people stare it
makes people react in in weird ways you
know so I wanted to bring that important
topic into awareness so sue Lagasse
Kadaga that is the first component I
have brought the awareness of grand mal
epilepsy into the film and as an actor
as a glamorous actor I mean I'm pretty
much I don't know if it's fortunate or
unfortunate but my popularity is a lot
to do with the glamorous aspect of me
whereas when I think about myself I I
don't think of me as that that glamorous
person at all I mean for me I'm just
that that human that thinking human who
wants to keep doing to keep creating so
I'm it will give the audience a shock to
see my acting in that because obviously
i play the protagonist in that film and
i have seen according to my life
expectancies i have portrayed that
correct
with the grand mal epilepsy and i know
it will shock people because they will
not expect to see that glamorous me with
that vulnerable condition in public you
know so that that is the first component
second component is we have brought in a
split-screen technology you know it has
been done before of course but we have
tried to do something very interesting
where same woman same time frame in life
if the reaction to the same condition is
different by the people around her how
will her life be different you know that
is that is something which I was really
wanting to to pull off and I think we
have pulled it off brilliantly so that
will show people okay a reaction like
this by society what happens to the
woman down the road a reaction simple
change of attitude mindset change of
mindset people around how life can take
it differently you know so that is the
second component third one is we have
brought in the hope angle and I all like
I already told you my films always have
to have hope you know I do not like to
end it with the sadness and the the
plight because we see we see it all the
time you know I have to give something
which says that okay how do we counter
this how do we how do we get one step
better than what what it is already so
the hope angle and that hope angle is
where I have brought in something which
I have always wanted to learn martial
arts ever since I was a child but that
one option it did not somehow it did not
come into my life because you know this
is just the way I I I was my education
my artistic background and all I didn't
have time I didn't have access to
martial arts and that time to learn so
it never was part of my life so I
brought that in I practiced and we have
pulled off an excellent I think I think
it's an excellent martial arts fight
scene there and my complete inspiration
was Bruce Lee because I have always been
a great admirer great admirer not only
of his work but of his life philosophies
because the more you you research
him and you see his arm his interviews
and his writings you see that his entire
martial art is based on the protection
of humanity and the enhancement of
humanity he always talks about that he
talks about it as a principle which
enhances like not destruction of life so
even all that violence in the the films
and then you see the the his philosophy
behind it is always self-defense
protection your martial and that that
factor we are brought in and not only
that we've also had we have shown
martial arts and how the story ends with
hope I won't tell the whole story but
that other component is there and and in
fact this year is his 75th birth
anniversary incidentally I did not know
this while I was making the film so I
was very happy because I had the chance
to actually go to the 75th birth
anniversary celebrations in Las Vegas a
month ago and meet the family of Bruce
Lee oh so it was a it was a beautiful
moment and they I heard them talking on
stage and at the anecdotes of his life
and things that I didn't know because I
I only know from media other previous
media so now I had the opportunity to
meet and interact with them and it was a
I felt it was a blessed moment for me so
the character that you play in your film
how is she similar to bruce lee and his
philosophies the initial character is
not because i'm showing that the how the
spiral goes downwards but how she comes
out of it thus the like I said the split
carrick the split technology where the
positivity is happening how she comes
out of it is where the martial arts
angle comes in and that martial arts
angle is is inspired by bruce lee's
principles and how she learns how the
discipline happens and how the final
climax happens in tucson so that is that
is what is inspired so it's a shift in
her mind
and her physicality yes not yes not only
in her mind it is also the interesting
part is I've shown how social situations
how people react to her can change her
mind set you know what I mean most many
times in woman disempowerment scenarios
or in women suffering scenarios the
reason she is suffering is because of
the attitudes of the people around her
how they are seeing what she does as
negative or repressive or how they try
to suppress her right I mean it's the
reactions or how physically dangerous
the situation can be because of the
people around her how they look at women
right as an object so many times it's
the people around her if that attitude
changes her life can change basically so
that component is what we have tried to
bring in also by saying is not just her
strength and her mindset people's
attitudes need to change the entire
collective mindset has to change how man
thinks about women how a previous
generation woman thinks about this
generations woman in other words we need
to support each other as women you know
so that angle I brought about so yeah
these these are the essential components
and I'm very excited and I would love
for all the film courage viewers to
watch this interview to watch the film
and love it and support it and let's
take it all forward because our the team
that has created it is again given their
heart mind and soul to the film and both
both in India and in Tucson and directed
by sandeep milani Scott Barker produced
by house of pundit and all the other
actors cast and crew so your support
will mean a lot the world support would
mean a lot so we can continue creating
films which bring awareness we we start
benefiting causes worldwide that's my
goal also obviously with as we grow big
go I want to have screenings which
benefit those causes that's that's
definitely one of my main goals because
as you know financial support is one of
the biggest things that we need also for
all these causes makes a huge difference
so it is a commercial film this is not
something which I would say is a public
service film it's a commercial film but
with that commercial film with with
audience support we can take it to grade
levels so that's what I'm planning to do
thank you so much guarantor the
wonderful time give it to me and I am
very thankful that we can put out these
ideas to the world and have all the
audiences love it thank you thank you so
much